What's up squad fam?!
I'm so excited for this game..
It's made by the same people that made Broforce, Genital Jousting,
and now they made one for the VR called Gorn.
I tried to get this game working a few days ago, and I'm like,
" ca- I can't get it to work.
I can't f*cking get it to work
[Censored with a dolphin sound]
I'm not smart enough. Look at my f*cking setup.
This is what it took to get this sh*t to work.
God bless you, VR,
you really innovated something, didn't you?
Wow.
Now if you some reason have a VR device,
you have to get this game, okay?
This looks so f*cking fun.
I watched Jack play it, it's super fun.
I act- I actually recommend checking him playing it out.
[good job]
I- If you haven't watched me play it - which you haven't - so check me out first.
I'm more important. You're here now.
Okay, let's just play it. Let's just f*cking play it. I just wanna play it,
I just really really, really wanna play it.
Alright so, huh[?], I can change the options over there.
Uhh
I don't know, I guess I'll just..
.. Keep goin into battle?
Oh my God, I've got a mace now!
King: "Salute me, and you battle!"
I will fight you!
yEAAAH!!
wOOOOO! Boom!
Daddy is hungry, daddy is hungry
Come on! Come on!
fight meh
I have the power of God and Anime by my side!!
[The enemy grunts.]
aaaaAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA A A A A A A A A A A A A A
Throw it!!
[The unconscious swole man grunts]
Got 'em!!
Oh, God. Oh, God.
[Pewds grunts.]
Don't catch me.
I have the power-
Swole man: The king [??]
[audience is laughing]
No
block
Blocked, blocked again again what you gonna do-OH block block- I just hit something..
ah we're fine
yes, yes, ah
Goddamn I'm good at this. This is a good exercise. I gotta say
Another one please, this is so fun. What'd I do wrong?
Where'd it go?!
Where's my ****
I had a-
It was right there! There was a mace right there- oh he look super dangerous. I'm running. I'm running
okay, I-I-I-um-
I think I died... maybe next time we'll pick up the actual weapon. WOO! There we go
Thank you. Yeah, I'm ready where did my weapon last time it just ***ing disappeared
Come on you F***S
Who wants some, huh? Who wants some??
What'd I say?! Wait for youR F***ING TURN! Oh my God he caught my mace-
Listen here, boy. Listen here, boy you don't want to mess with me boy- Did he seriously kill me?
Charging this one..
'M charging this one!
Come on, ah, come on!
That *ss is mine, that *ss is mine!
Run, run Felix! Run, they're dangerous! F***ing, ah, f***ing punches doesn't always work...
Alright, let's just take care of this son of a b***
How you doing?
Cool.
You like that, baby? Oh god-
I think he's dead.
OH no. No, block!
Yeah I blocked a..[???]
Block, block, yeah
C'mere, c'mere, c'mere. Yeah, uh- I killed him, for f***'s sake. You die way too easy in this game
Let's just take this guy out first...
I'm legit just playing the game at this point
W- [Dolphin noises]
That's right...
C'mere...
*grunt*
*sex noises*
A FEW MOMENTS LATER
*sex noises* Who's been naughty?*more sex noises*
Ah sh** there we go
I didn't realize...gimme that sh**....
*even more sex noises*
This... is pretty tough
Come here... come here
That´s f*cking right WHAT ELSE?
Anyone f*cking else, are you not entertained. My name is Morpheus, Poodiepiedius
Ah,sorry, yes
YOU WANT THIS!!?!
Yeah, that's what i´m talk... *pewdz hits the wall* that's what I'm talking about
Are you kidding me? This is so f*cking stupid.
I'm getting sweaty playing video games what the f*ck I don't like this
COME ON!!
This is so f*cking hard
F*CK YOU!!
No, stop!
f*cking me!
bad boy bad F*CKING boy!
F*ck you I'm done!
What did I get huh? What did I F*CKING GET?!
Not a doub- I GOT IT!! F*CK ALL OF YOU! F*CKS!!
That's f*cking right.
*sigh of relief*
Thank you, that was so hard my God.
Yeah!
WOAH!!!
OHHHHH!!!
Oh I have a spear!
WOOooaaAAAHH WOAH!
Frah! Frah!
Brrah! Brrah!
Oh god...
What do I do.
I lost my equipment.
Yeah, yes!
Thats how they f*cked back in the anchent times
WOAH woah Cha! Woah woah! Whooo Whooo!
I Love the spear it's f*cking amazing
Come on.
I HAVE THE POWER OF GOD AND ANIME ON MY SIDE
AAHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!!!
Uh oh
My God look at that face. I'm dying
wOOOAAH!
That was so fun. Oh
Oh my god.
Alright guys, that's it for me for now. Thank you for leaving a like on this video, and uh... gender fist.